Guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Kanay.
Guten Tag. Ja, nochmal bitte. Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Kanay. Ich bin Social Dendekürse.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Annamnese-Geschöpftisch führen,
kurzum Ablauf für die ich nach Ihren Personenschandaten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Manfred Sonntag.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben.
Manfred wie Martha Anton, Sie haben gesagt langsam.
Anton Nordpupul Friedrich Richard Emil Dohrer.
Nachname Sonntag wieder Sonntag, den wir kennen.
S-o-n-n-t-a-g.
Herr Sonntag, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie denn auch geboren?
Ich bin am 11. Mai 1988 geworden.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 175 groß und wiege 87 kg.
Sie sind 88 kg.
Herr Sonntag, wie sehen Sie uns?
Ich habe seit einer Woche Schmerzen im Bereich meiner Halswirbelsäule.
Insbesondere wenn ich meinen Kopf nach rechts drehe, das geht nicht.
Dann habe ich starke Schmerzen, die in meinem rechten Arm aufstrahlen.
Sie sind plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Ich würde sagen, vor einer Woche hat es angefangen, aber nach ein, zwei Tagen war die Schmerz sehr stark.
Es war zunehmend Schmerz.
Ist Ihnen dafür einen Auslöser aufgefallen?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Haben Sie etwas schwere Sachen geholfen oder sind Sie verlessen?
Haben Sie sich verletzt?
Nein, nicht das Schwere.
Wie beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen, sind die Schmerzen erheblich, sind die Siehende, die Brennende?
Siehende Schmerzen, würde ich sagen.
Es zieht so in meinen ganzen Arm durch bis zu meinem Baum.
Wenn ich nach rechts der Kopf drehe, dann zieht es noch stärker.
Okay.
Haben Sie Einschränkungen beim Kopf drehen?
Ja, ich kann nicht ganz nach rechts gucken.
Wir sind auf einer Schmerz, wobei noch kein Schmerz sind.
Sie sind starkstischmärzend.
Ich würde sagen sieben.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen zu Hause etwas Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe die Profäne eingenommen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
600 Milligramm.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, es hat meine Schmerzengelinde geholfen.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie eben vorhin eingenommen?
Die letzten Tage habe ich die drei Mal am Tag genommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie solche Schmerzen erst mal gehabt?
Zum ersten Jahr.
Wie jetzt habe ich das nie gehabt bis jetzt?
Ja, zum ersten Mal.
Fühlen Sie sich in deinem Arm Taubheit gefühlt?
Ja, mein rechter Taub ist ein bisschen taub.
Und haben Sie sich schwach gefühlt in deinem Arm?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Schwächer gefühlt.
Und können Sie kribbeln?
Nein.
Können Sie eine Tasse gut halten?
Ja, es geht.
Ich kann es halten.
Ich will ein Übel und ein Schwindel.
Nein.
Ja, herrsch, so.
Haben Sie sonstige Beschwerden mit Atmen und Herzchen?
Schüpeln Sie Herzrahmen?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist es beim Masse- und Verdammensystem?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Nein.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Haben Sie vielfach zu Taubrost?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Schmerz?
Sie wissen Sie mehr als vorher?
Nee.
Und ich möchte wissen,
haben Sie in der letzten Zeit den Umgewollte ab oder so genommen?
Nein, ungefähr gleich.
Und 1-2 kg zu oder ab, aber nicht in großen Mengen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist normal gut.
Und Sie sitzen bei der Arbeit überwiegend?
Oder gehen oder stehen mehr?
Nein, ich sitze viel.
Ich habe ein Bürojob.
Okay, arbeiten Sie mit dem Computer?
Ja.
Sonntag schüpeln Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ich hab noch nicht die Zeit,
ich habe nur die Zeit für den Umgewollte.
Genau, das meine ich.
Das meine ich.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie ich mich mit dem Computer verursacht habe.
Das meine ich.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich mit dem Computer verursacht habe.
Genau das meine ich und das meine ich auch jetzt über Covid bin ich angemft.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Medikamente, Leven Smith dar?
Gegenüber Medikamente bin ich allergisch, ja.
Welche Medikamente?
Das ist Penicillin.
Penicillin. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Atemnot.
Können Sie alle Leven Smith-Teile gut vertragen?
Ich denke schon, weiß ich nicht. Jetzt bin ich nichts aufgefallen.
Herr Sonntag sind Sie jung, aber vielleicht erleiden Sie
irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Wie zum Beispiel, was meinen Sie mit Vorerkrankungen?
Wie Bluthochdruck?
Bluthochdruck habe ich nicht.
Herr Schöpfel, der zweite.
Nein, du habe ich nicht mehr, sondern weiß ich nicht, ob die erhöht sind.
Okay.
Einzige, was ich hatte, ist mit 17 Jahren hatte ich eine Blinddarm-Entfernung.
Eine Operation.
Dabei hat man mir Antibiotikum gegeben und daher weiß ich, dass ich da allergisch reagiere.
Okay.
Das war die Operation Komplikation losverlaufen?
Ja, die OP ist Komplikation losverlaufen, aber postoperativ hat man mir Antibiotika gegeben
und da habe ich allergisch reagiert.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente, regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Bei Bedarf, die im Profil ab und zu mal, wenn man Fußball spielt oder irgendwas ist,
dann tut mir eben etwas weh und dann nehme ich den Profil und meinst meistens ist es gut, aber dies war halt nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe gesagt, bei Fußball spielen, schüpeln Sie, schmerzen Sie, wosent ihr schmerzen Sie?
Ja, wenn die Mensch jemand fault, dann nicht in dem Machenbereich.
Mein Fuß unterschenkelt, da wird einmal falsch getreten oder man fällt auf das Knie, aber nicht jetzt, das war früher.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt nicht aktuell.
Ja, haben Ihre Eltern, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Eltern, ja, die leben.
Sind Sie gesund?
Mein Vater nimmt irgendein Medikament wegen Bluthoffdruck und meine Mutter nimmt Medikament wegen ihrer Schilddrüse, die wurde mal operiert.
Aber was sie dann nimmt, weiß ich nicht.
Da wurde, glaube ich, die komplette Schilddrüse entwähnt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister vielleicht?
Geschwister, ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich möchte wissen, über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten rauchen Sie?
Rauchen?
Nee.
Haben Sie niemals geraucht?
Nee, ich habe mal einmal probiert oder so, aber das war nicht richtig rauchen.
Okay, dann können Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das haben Sie zum Beispiel schon, oder?
Wie machen Sie?
Ja, bei Anlässen wie zum Beispiel einer Geburtstagssfeier, oder?
Besonders anders, wenn ich mit Freunden zu diskutieren oder so, dann täckne ich mal ein bisschen Alkohol, sonst ist es nicht regelmäßig.
Was für Alkohol trinken Sie?
Wein, Bier?
Wein nicht, Bier oder Whiskey oder so was in der Richtung.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Drogen, nee.
Was machen Sie beruflich herzlichen?
Beruflich, ich bin Programmierer.
Ich arbeite in der IT-Brunche.
Sind Sie mit der Arbeit zufrieden?
Haben Sie die Dresdbeidearbeit?
Die Dresdbeidearbeit, aber nicht ein negativer Stress.
Manchmal gibt es mehr Aufträge oder Zeit, ist es sehr eng.
Stress gibt es immer, aber mir macht meine Arbeit Spaß.
Okay, gut, das freut mich.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstudent?
Mein Familienstudent, ich bin nicht verheiratet, ich bin ledig.
Aber eine Freundin.
Leben Sie zusammen mit Ihrer Freundin?
Wir leben getrennt.
Okay.
Leben Sie allein oder?
Ja, ich bin ein Familienstudent.
Ja.
Machen Sie regelmäßig sportliche Aktivitäten?
Sie haben schon gesagt, die Fußballspiele?
Ja, ich bin mit meinen Kollegen und Freunden.
Ich spiele einmal die Woche Fußball.
Okay.
Sonst noch was?
Fahrer Fahrrad, unregelmäßig, sonst mache ich keinen Sport.
Ja, Sonntag.
Ich habe eine wichtige Frage nicht getragen,
Sie möchten noch etwas vergeben?
Ja, Frau Doktor, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was habe ich denn eigentlich?
Können Sie mir helfen?
Ja.
Wie geht es weiter?
Sie haben jetzt ein Tag sich machen.
Ich werde Ihnen ein Tag sich machen,
verabreicht.
Ich werde Sie gleich körperlich unterhalten.
Ich werde Sie auch körperlich unterhalten.
Danach würde ich ein paar Bildgevern passeden.
Ich habe 47
lösen bei verschiedenen Krankheiten aus.
Die Ursache herauszufinden brauche ich noch ein paar Untersuchungen und ja, Körperlöschen und Untersuchungen.
Okay, hoffe ich, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein.
Ertag.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja.
Spüren Sie Nackensteifigkeit?
Nackensteifigkeit.
Nee, würde ich nicht sagen.
Oder Verspannung? Keine.
Spannung würde ich sagen.
Ja, so zieht mir den Muskel in der Hand für Besolder so rechts, zieht mir bis zu meinem Schulterbrat.
Strahlung, Ausstrahlung, hat gefragt?
Ja, wurde gefragt.
Es zieht Schmerzaufstrahlung ein bisschen in meinem Darf.
Haben Sie in diesem Bereich Belästchen bemerkt?
Belästchen bemerkt.
Also Hautveränderung, meine Sie.
Ja.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Zeckenstich gehabt?
Ein Was? Zecken?
Ja.
Nicht, dass ich gesehen habe, oder?
Das auch gefallen wäre, nein.
Okay.
Können wir anfangen, Sultan?
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Sie sind mal los.
Ja, es geht um Manfred Sonntag.
Er ist 34 Jahre alt, am 11.05.1988 geboren.
Und ein Metaf 75 Kurus, 87 Kilo Schiver.
Herr Sonntag, sie teilte sich bei uns,
wegen seit einer Woche langsam auf Treten,
Bestehender zu nehmen,
Nakand Schmerzen,
mit Ausstrahlung in den rechten Arm bis Dahmen vor.
Das ist der Dahmen, der ausmacht.
Die Schmerz-Intensität liegt bei Zeben von Sen auf einer Schmerz-Sykela.
Die Frage nach Schöpferliche Belastungen wurden verletzt und
wurden verneint.
Er hat bis jetzt dreimal,
dreimal, täglich gegen Schmerzen,
überführen, 660 Gramm eingenommen.
Das hat ihm ein Mission geholfen.
Herr Sonntag gelackt über Kipostezi
in den rechten Dahmenbereich.
Die Bekanntheitrebe an Amnesi war unauffällig.
Beim Kopftrehen verlechtert sich die Schmerzen
besonders nach rechten Seite.
Wie können Sie es sonst beschreiben?
Bei Kopftrehen nach rechten Seite.
Wie nennt man das in unserer Fachsprache?
Bei Rotation nach rechts.
Die Frage nach Parisien und Parästhesien wurden verneint.
Das ist bei ihm keine Vorerkrankung bekannt.
Es ist bei ihm mit 70 Jahren eine Appendiptomie erfolgt.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf ein Tablet ein.
Er ist von Sternen geheim.
Er ist allergisch gegen Penicillin und reagiert darauf mit Anaphylaxie.
Es sind keine unverträglichen Bekannte.
Er ist nicht rauf.
Er hat z.B. selten Alkohol.
Er ist ein sehr besonderer Anlass.
Er hat eine gesunde Schwester.
Er ist ein Programmeer bei einem Brot.
Er arbeitet überwiegend sitzen.
Er ist ein Freund.
Er ist ein Sport-Aktiviertel.
Patienten aus frisch-körperlich unterzuholen.
Bei der Unterzuhaltung achte ich darauf, ob eine Parästisien in den rechten Arm gibt oder Parästisien gibt.
Ich berühre mit einem Wattebaum und dann kann ich vielleicht bescheiden, ob eine Parästisien gibt.
Als Bilgebernesparfum würde ich erst Röntgenaufnahme von Hospitality und Soil auf der Weihebene veranlasen.
Wenn es eine Nervenverletzung gibt, würde ich eine Magnetresonastomografie von Passverbandsoil durchführen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen den beiden Aufnahmen? Was können Sie beim Röntgen erkennen oder nicht erkennen?
Was können Sie beim MRT vor und nach teilen?
Bei der Röntgenaufnahme kann ich eine Fraktur und eine Verbildung von Hass-Virguss-Soyle dargestellt werden.
Wie ist die Verbildung?
Meine zweite Verdachtdiagnose ist eine stilische Teilung.
Stilstellung, deswegen kann ich vielleicht
an der Terrale als variable Frontgen,
diese Saisen finden.
Ich habe falsch gesprochen. Stilstellung, oder?
Stilstellung, meinein Sie.
Eine Fehlhaltung, Sie können auch generell sagen,
um eine Fehlhaltung, Sie haben vorhin irgendwas gesagt,
mit Fehl, nicht Fehl, irgendwas anderes gesagt, also angeborene,
irgendwas gesagt, eine Fehlhaltung, kann man verstehen.
Also eine Stilstellung oder eine Hypokryphysiore, oder irgendwas.
Was kann man sonst im Röntgen sehen zum Beispiel?
Was kann man interpretieren?
Unsere Patienten ist...
Nicht bei den Patienten, sondern generell...
Aussturoporosisaisen kann ich nicht.
Vielleicht ja, und was noch?
Spondylose, Saisen, Ankylose.
Okay, können Sie so ein Bild beschreiben zum Beispiel,
der Bandscheibenfach, wenn der sich verschleißt.
Wie würde das heißen?
Ja, in Sarwebrialle des Kichupolte ist der Verminderter sein.
Genau, der Höhenverminderung des Bandscheibenfaches,
könnte man auch sagen.
Oder man nennt es auch Osteoschondrosa zum Beispiel.
Osteoschondrosa, okay.
Man könnte Facettengelenke, also die Bibelbubengelenke auch
ösenteils sehen, sozusagen, ob da ein Arthrose entsteht, ein standendes,
oder irgendwelches Pathologien, wie irgendwelche Tumore, Raumforderungen.
Könnte man eventuell aussehen, nicht alles, aber kann man schon einiges erkennen.
Und im MRT, was kann man da sehen? Was ist der Vorteil von MRT?
Ja, mit der MRT kann ich die Weissteile von Organen vergisst werden,
Szenen und Bandenverletzungen.
Würde ich genau betrachten.
Wenn eine Prolapsus gibt, werde ich bei der MRT bezieht.
Also, meistens kann man entseht man, ob eine Spinalkalastrosa ist,
durch Bending von Arthrose, von den Facettengelenken,
oder durch Bandscheibenvorwirkung, Vorfall.
Kann dadurch eine Spinalkalastrosa entstehen
oder durch degenerative Veränderung kann es zu einem Neurovorrahmen-Stenose kommen, zum Beispiel.
Nerven-Ausrittseinigung heißt es dann auf Deutsch.
Das kann man da beurteilen hauptsächlich.
Natürlich kann man auch Ideen sehen, als Zeichen einer entzündlichen Reaktion
oder Zeichen einer Fraktur-Tumore, das kann man dort manchmal feststellen,
dass man im Röntgen nichts sieht.
Nehmen wir mal an, dieser Mensch hat einen Bandscheibenvorfall
auf der Höhe C5-6, rechtsseitig.
Was würden Sie dem Patienten empfehlen?
Ich würde erst eine Analyse für die Reaktionen,
die wir für die Muskelreaktionen haben,
für die Verabreichung.
Was für eine Analyse können Sie geben?
Sideroidale antiromatica, für die Verabreichung.
Wenn Sie einen Bandscheibenvorfall sehen
und der hat eine Aufstellung in den rechten Arm,
dann kann man die Analyse auf der Sitzung kommen.
Wenn man nicht an die Analyse vergeben kann,
kann man auch zusätzlich an die Infusion,
die Cortison verabreichen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Wie viel Milligramm, zum Beispiel der Dexamethasone,
würde ich je nach Stärke 8 Milligramm oder 12 Milligramm geben,
je nach Klinik.
Und dann weiter an den Analyse,
kann man zusätzlich ergänzen.
Zum Beispiel.
Anesthetik,
Anesthetik.
Ich meine, Infusion, Sie geben jetzt eine Infusion zum Beispiel.
Sie möchten eine Infusion geben, da haben Sie jetzt
diese Kochstattslösung, Dexamethasone gegeben.
Was könnten Sie da noch reingeben?
Meinen Zimuskulreaktion?
Ne, Schmerzmittel.
Metamizon?
Metamizon, genau.
Kann man dazu geben,
wenn noch stärker der Schmerz ist, könnte man auch etwas anderes noch geben, zum Beispiel.
Opioid.
Sozusagen, oder eine Vorstufe, Dramat, zum Beispiel, kann man auch geben.
Okay, also Sie würden einmal mit einer Schmerztherapie
anfangen, was würden Sie noch machen?
Würden Sie die Basicware,
würden Sie operieren empfehlen oder nicht?
Je nachdem, grüße von Quantayben-Forfall,
können wir eine Operation durchführen.
Eine mikroschereurbische Operation.
Aber unsere Patienten, keine Parasites.
Ich habe keine,
ich habe keine,
keine Parasites.
Genau, also die Richtlinien,
die Empfehlung der wirbelsohnen Chirurgium, die sagen,
wenn keine Lehmung, also eine Paräse, da ist,
muss man auch nicht erst mal operieren.
Erst mal konservativ versuchen.
Also Infusion weiter.
Also keine Lehmung oder Teillehmung.
Also machen wir eine, leitern wir eine konservative Therapie ein.
Krankengymnastik, Wärmtherapie,
würde ich empfehlen.
Die Muskeln zu starten.
Genau, um zu mobilisieren, zu stärken.
Und Wärmtherapie macht man, warum?
Warum macht man Sie eine Wärmtherapie, wozu ist es gut?
Ja, weil der Wärmtherapie,
wenn dann die Schmerzen.
Ja, genau, welche Schmerzen, die muskuläre Schmerzen.
Der Muskel möchte warm haben, der möchte locker werden.
Ja, absolut.
Du siehst, ich kann man auch eine Massage verschreiben zum Beispiel.
Anordnen.
Und gut.
Da gibt es noch andere Sachen,
wie dass man lokale Infiltrationen macht.
CT-Gestörte nennt man PRT,
pereidekläre Infiltration mit Kontison.
Auch wenn man den Nervenwurzel,
der auch gereizt ist, die Entzündung wegnemen möchte,
kann man auch machen.
Man kann auch, wenn man das auch grob gesagt ist,
bevor man, was ich damit sagen wollte,
Entscheidung OP, nein, es gibt nicht mehr der OP oder nicht OP,
um die OP zu sagen, wenn jemand eine Pariser hat,
eine schwäche Gefühle in der Arm hat,
der Befund passt dazu,
dass der auf der Etage 5, 6, C5, 6,
und ein eigen Reflex bei der Untersuchung auch unfällig ist,
dann geht es in Richtung Operation.
Wenn der Bandscheid vor Fall riesengroß ist,
und auch keine Teilhähmung da ist,
könnte man aber auch operieren,
weil da wenn ein Riesenvorfall ist,
erwartet man nicht, dass es besser wird.
Es ist Einzelfallentscheidung letztendlich.
Was ist die Ursache in diesem Fall?
Vielleicht, das kann man nie sagen,
ob der jetzt in seinem Berufssjob die Monitor falsch eingestellt hat,
oder beim Fußballspiel mal Kopfball gemacht hat,
irgendwann mal früher.
Und über die längere Zeit entsteht manche,
bei manchen Personen eine Degeneration.
Vielleicht ist genetisch bedingt,
dass man die Kapsel nicht sehr stark ist,
und mehrere Faktoren führen dazu.
Hier sieht man nicht, warum es das hat,
aber es kommt manchmal.
Man muss nichts besonderer Ereignis haben,
und manche haben etwas zu bekommen.
Es gibt in Amerika eine Studie,
wo die Leute nie Rückenschmerzen hatten,
und trotzdem Bandscheid vor Fall haben.
Man hat Rückenschmerzen in der MRT eingetan,
mit 1.000 Leute.
Und bei ungefähr 160 Leuten hat man Bandscheid vor Fallfallfallfall.
Das heißt, es stehen manchmal Bandscheid vor Fallfallfall,
die wir nie klinisch waren, immer subklinisch abgelaufen sind.
Dann kommt dann irgendein Ereignis, z.B. schläft der falsch,
Kissen irgendwie nicht gehabt.
Und dann reizt das, zum Beispiel, das kann auch sein,
ob der frisch ist oder nicht frisch ist,
dieser Bandscheid vor Fallfall.
Man kann alles Spekulationen, dann weiter, weiter.
Manchmal hat jemand Akute Lumbar Gau, z.B.,
bei Facetum-Syndrom, Rücken,
und geht zum MRT, sagen die, sie haben ein Bandscheid,
aber vielleicht hat er seit 5 Jahren Bandscheid vor Fallfall,
und hat keine Symptomatik haben.
Also ist alles relativ, sozusagen.
Bei der Bandscheid vor Fallfall ist ein Hauskreus kontrinsiert,
oder nicht erfüllen wird?
Ja, verschreibt man, deswegen gibt es das auch auf dem Markt,
ich bin einer der wenig, das verschreibt.
Aber wenn man das verschreibt, muss man darauf hinweisen,
dass man das nicht lange trägt,
sondern nur für 2, 3 Stunden oder so am Tag.
Also dann Pausen, also nicht tragen,
sondern eher, wenn es geht, nicht tragen als tragen,
aber manchmal als Schmerztherapie,
das ist eine halb-scroll-Serie erleichtert,
weil der Kopf gehalten wird.
Aber wenn man zu lange trägt, dann gibt es Muskelabbau,
sozusagen Muskel,
wie heißt das nochmal?
Atrophie, das ist der Wort, wie man hier,
kann es zu einem Mutselatrophie geben,
und das macht dann wiederum später andere Probleme.
Okay.
Intre vertebrelle Bereiche,
kann man ein Steroid oder Opioid geben?
Opioid nicht.
Man kann, was ich vorhin gesagt habe,
mit CT gesteuert,
kann man meistens an den Nervenwurzel ausgängen,
wo der Nervenwurzel ist,
Neuroforamenbereich,
kann man Steroid geben,
oder wir hatten, wo ich gelernt habe,
sozusagen, es machen weniger Krankräuser,
dass man unter einem C-Wogen
oder einer Röntgenkontrolle mit Kontrastmittel,
weil das ist schwierig,
weil wenn man in den Kanal kommt,
sehr nah ist dort der Rückenmark,
den kann man verletzen,
und deswegen kann man vorsichtig
unter Gabe mit Kontrastmittel, manuell,
gucken, dass man gerade in den periodoral Raum kommt
und dann kann man den Kanäle wechseln
und dort auch Kurtison geben.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich nicht mache,
da schicke ich die Leute dorthin,
wo die es sehr oft machen.
Ansonsten mache ich sehr viel kontrovertiv selber.
Warum macht in Deutschland
die Neurochirurgen oder Orthopedisten,
diese Eingriff?
Das, was ich gemacht habe mit dem,
das ist orthopedisch.
Meistens machen das die Kliniken in Nordrhein-Westfalen,
weil da gab es früher ein Prof. Kremer in Buchung,
den gibt es nicht mehr, der ist verstorben,
und deren obererste Ascenzer,
die fachnitzige Wurzel sind,
machen in Bereichen Nordrhein-Westfalen
um den Buchnauer rum.
Oder bis nach Frankfurt, ich bin in der Nähe von Frankfurt,
ich war aber auf meiner Facharzt-Ausbildung
dort gemacht und dort ist erlernt.
Es ist eine Technik,
die nicht so oft gemacht wird.
Die meisten lassen durch die Radiologen
eine PRT machen, und das war es.
Die Neurochirurgen machen das auch selten.
Ich denke, das macht die Schinke alle zum Radiologen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, danke schön.
Was ist Ihre Prüfung?
Nach der nächsten Mitte.
Kommt ihr mit vor oder darauf?
Also gut.
Hat jemand in der Gruppe noch Fragen?
Keiner.